well it goes like this I'm going to make
three statements and one of them is a
lie okay you have to decide which one it
is okay very good
the first film I ever made was never
released I turned down the role of
Dumbledore in Harry Potter named Kate
Beckinsale once proposed marriage I can
absolutely understand a beautiful young
woman
proposing marriage to you well kind of
it's very believable so I'll go for the
Dumbledore one being alive well that's
correct I just said all right you ready
for mine yes good I once slept on the
ground for three months number two I
speak French no before no sorry Dom
three I can't count
I was once arrested for impersonating a
police officer that's the lie I'm
someone keeping the score God is keeping
the score and we are tickety-boo
I once sang in a Pet Shop Boys Vidya
I played King Lear in the opening
ceremony of the Paralympic Games 2012 in
London and I am a licensed minister yes
I was playing a version of a prosper
another cat I once spent the night at a
real brothel doing research for a role
of course you did this weather is
actually for research the point is I did
I have three figures at Madame Tussauds
I completed a half marathon really where
did you run can remember which where was
it yes it was through Putney London hmm
so which one was a lie darling the
second one great we never run a marathon
Oh have you of course not Oh drum
[Music]